Americans do agree on certain things you
wouldn't know that if you know from the
duck dynasty thing of we lie everyone
loves gays or hates gays or Obamacare
roll a dura the whole thing everything
there we tell us we're so polarized but
actually Time magazine did a little
survey and it turns out that when it
comes to pot abortion gays some of the
big social stuff that we talk a lot
about Americans pretty much agree on
that stuff so on weed legalization
fifty-eight percent of americans say the
drugs should be legal okay on abortion
seventy-eight percent think abortion
should be legal under all or some
circumstances and just twenty percent
think it should be illegal in all
circumstances on homosexuality I like
how they worded it like that really
let's focus on the homo part in 2013
fifty-nine percent thought gay or
lesbian relations were morally
acceptable fifty-three percent are now
in favor of same-sex marriage in terms
of health insurance fifty-six percent
believe that it is not the
responsibility of the federal government
to make sure all Americans have health
care coverage I think that's kind of
interesting which is up from twenty
eight percent in 2006 so that's a little
backwards to where we've been going with
Obamacare and then finally trust in
government just nineteen percent of
Americans trust the government in
Washington to do what's right that seems
high to me eighty-one percent of us
don't expect the government to do what's
right all or most of the time that seems
low to me and a record high seventy-two
percent believe the government will be
the biggest threat to the country in the
future sorry let's we'll start backwards
that sort of goes to what we were just
talking about about guns and the NSA and
all that so let's just talk about this
purely in terms of the government this
is really really bad news if you're a
government guy here and you're it's
really bad news for everyone who's
financially supporting the government
pouring money into the government all
that seems to be the where the money is
going yeah I think Americans are
starting to notice that the government
is really financially controlled and
that's so much money goes into our
government that we're starting to
question why and I think that's when the
distrust starts I think you don't trust
people when they're making decisions
based on their own interest when a small
group of people has all the money in the
country and is basically putting more
money to keep their interest hi I think
we're starting to be aware of that and
why would you trust people like that I
don't think all people in government or
you know not trustworthy or trying to do
something negative
hurt you there's no like evil empire
going on to the system is set up right
now and people are starting to wake up
yeah I mean it is just this giant
sucking system so as a you're you're
still a registered Republican if I'm not
mistaken right so as a wii u in
california right so as a republican you
want smaller government so are those all
the reasons why you want smaller
government i think some of those numbers
are very much that because we're seeing
government and particularly the elected
officials who are so unpopular all
politics is selfish and we know that and
and the problem though with the
politicians particularly in Washington
are their only goal in life is that next
election they're not concerned about
doing what's right for the country or
their constituents they just want to
worry about what's happening when
they're next on the ballot moving up or
so that's one of the big problems and
that's why Congress has held in such
poor esteem but I think overall there's
confidence somewhat in government
although these are conflicting numbers
but are Twain and talked about you know
lies damn lies and statistics and I
think that's what a lot of these polls
show is very confusing I think that in
in situation where we need to rally
around government the American public is
there and believes in government and
they said that they're doing they think
they're trying to do the right thing
eighty-one percent yeah we're still
country that's very divided and we have
a lot of differing opinions and I think
some of the social issues are great the
media we can thank for that all the
coverage of all these happy couples in
Utah which was really made my Christmas
that gay marriage was legal therefore to
me for what we get two weeks and now now
he probably go to go to Supreme Court oh
yeah thirteen hundred and sixty couples
went in to take advantage of that and
marriages are in limbo but when you see
all that love and the families and that
the this waiting in line even cold and
even longer the the for the pot in
marijuana in Colorado I think that shows
the American public that it's not
harming anyone and just affording
happiness and love to others that's
what's changing numbers I agree with all
that except I disagree with the fact
that you know when you said that the
country is still very divided I think
that these numbers show the country
isn't really that divide it I mean
obviously the country is becoming more
socially liberal fiscally conservative
and the statistics are proving that
people want that especially by saying
less government and but kind of like
leave us alone so I think that we're not
as
vided as we think I think people in
general except for some very fringe
groups on either side kind of her like
you know why don't you just kind of like
leave us alone let us figure it out
people are getting smarter and more
informed as they get smarter and more
informed and see what you were saying
like see peoples weddings happening see
you know the people in Colorado are
running around committing crimes because
they're on weed they'll become a little
bit more relaxed and realize that we can
trust the people to make our own
decisions yet so Fred I'm gonna give you
some public props here so you ran for
president on the Republican ticket the
first openly gay man to run on a either
party platform you actually qualified
for the Fox News debate and they didn't
let you in but I think there's a lawsuit
involving that uh but but what you
believe in are the exact things that
Jen's talking about here that all these
people want this socially liberal let it
be nobody no woman wants an abortion but
she should have access to it if she
needs one uh the the gay stuff that we
obviously all agree on the guns all that
stuff is there do we need a third party
to do that or can one of these parties
actually make that happen I think we're
seeing a combination of a lot of people
left the two parties to become
independent I when I ran the New
Hampshire primary forty-two percent of
the registered voters in New Hampshire
are no political party their decline to
state why because they're unhappy with
the parties so the country shifts back
and forth it does from time to time and
the Republican Party right now is his
move so far right but it did I think
it'll come back to the center what about
chris christie if he runs he's perceived
as a lot more centrist to moderate but
we'll see because he there was a traffic
violation today i could derail his whole
presidency very lots of scandal there
knew that book double down you'll see
why the Romney didn't pick him for vice
president and they list all the reasons
which I think was a good kind of slap in
the face duh to Christie on his chances
but but is there a Chancellor a third
party or do you think it still has to
come out now this machine is very well
designed that it is impossible seeing
that no it's just the way the system is
set up with the primaries the caucuses
there's just no way for a third party to
really get in and also the Electoral
College that we can't really infiltrate
that I've been many you've tried but I
unless you get a Michael Bloomberg in
there that's
ross perot and it's still the states are
set up in the primary caucus system to
to stop such action yeah alright so
final thought on this the one that i
think is particularly interesting there
is the abortion because seventy eight
percent of people think that a woman
should have access to it in virtually
all cases but yet we still seem to have
a debate about abortion why can't is
this again the disc emotional emotional
aegis based and it's not really all
cases and i think a big bulk of that
that's pretty divided a lot of other
polls I've seen it's in rape in the case
of rape or incest where people well
that's what gets it to that 70 samples
and most now kind of her just like let
people have abortions in almost all
cases if they believe in abortion and
most people that don't believe in
abortion believe in it in no cases
that's where your statistically starting
to see is it's becoming even more and
more polarized within the people that
have an opinion on it as people that
also kind of don't care yeah and we
always discount that we always think
that everyone is like oh please give me
abortions or no abortions or a pee some
people just kind of don't care don't the
people that don't want abortion also
don't want sex head it's like pick one
get you know to give us one reason
religion it's really just reaching
that's what brainwashing people right in
order to come up with these positions
well I think it's interesting that you
know you you ran on the Republican
ticket and and you can say those things
and are free to say those things and
would have a larger problem being
elected in a primary because you know
you have to say things like nope you
know I love Jesus and no abortion and
all these things and you may love Jesus
and still think that people can have
abortions who knows but i think it's
difficult as a republican to have an
array of different opinions to get any
sort of credit into the primary yeah
well that's the irony we talked about it
for a second before the show but jon
huntsman was sort of thought of as a
joke and he was the only rational person
up there at least in my opinion so that
shows you that or at least i will be
accepted pretty well at least on on the
stage where you where you should have
been what do you do then what do you do
ask somebody who identifies as a
republican somebody who has different
ideas and some of the other people in
your party and maybe views that many
people have in your party but can't say
then what do you do what does the party
do you try and change from within and
the party republican party i grew up
with was a lot more moderate pic leah in
the civil rights area I blame the
Democratic Party for wrecking the
Republican Party Strom Thurmond
people like that switch from Democrats
Republicans after the Civil Rights Act
was passed by the Democratic Party and
so they've poisoned the well and now you
have the religious right that's taken
over but we're gonna fight a lot of
younger people that believe in fiscal
conservatism holding government
responsible better socially moderate or
I think are gonna come back their public
party if we get a good nominee and some
good leaders yeah and that's why again I
don't say Rand Paul twice but a guy like
Rand Paul he could be what a true
libertarian is and get out of bed room
that's what I don't get we were with you
on that as a they were with you on the
drone thing we want you know more of a
controlled government unless spending
and then at the same time still doesn't
believe in gay marriage I think he's
still for you know the weed stuff and
Bobby stable raised an unstable
individual yeah that would be easier
than a very emotional about the way that
he seems to pick his issues but it seems
so silly to me that when you're the
Republicans and you're fearing that you
might not win a few more elections why
would you play to your base of these
like total right-wing extremely no
chicks instead of realizing that you
could have win this country in a
landslide if you just put somebody cuz
look a lot of people perceive the
Democrats is weak right now people
aren't sure how they feel about Obama
people they're a little more liberal
liberal maple feel that Obama betrayed
them and didn't do everything he said he
was going to do people that are more
conservative don't like his health care
plan don't like a lot of different
things if you are a Republican advisor
it just seems so moronic to me to not go
let's cut the BS with pandering to tea
party right wing religious crazy
fanaticism and why don't we just pick a
sane candidate in the middle that is a
states rights person that's a less
government person that also says let's
just stop with a religious crap yeah